there's a foster couple outside mr.
Batson I can take care of myself give
these people a chance because that's
what they're giving you Billy is a
foster kid he's been in and out of
foster homes
this is Billy Batson he's a really good
kid who wants the best who sticks up for
the other kid hey man sorry about that
and because he was pure of heart baby
backs these transports of this wizard
I choose you as champion do and douse
him with his power of Shazam Shazam see
he has this power of just saying one
word and turning into a superhero first
he goes to see his friend Freddie you're
the only person I know that knows
anything about this Cape Crusader stuff
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing you okay why are you talking
like any kid who gains the power of
being and he's gonna go you shouldn't do
things that only adults can do does is a
casual balm Shazam is one of very few
superhero characters it is genuinely
stoked to be a superhero your punch
cards your phone charge no you're like a
bad guy right I just get to show up on
set and be like be good to do this I get
to fly around fight bad guys
you're dead
hey everybody is Charlie so they dropped
a whole bunch of new Shazam footage in
this big preview so we'll break it down
there's also news about what's going on
with Black Adam and Superman I've got a
whole bunch of questions because they've
been talking about post-credit scenes
and teasers special cameos we'll get to
it all we're still doing that Amazon
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailers so far
on the video a lot of the new footage
you can tell in the way that they talk
about the character is to distinguish
him from the other DC movies that have
come so far like Aquaman was a
dramatically different tone different
type of character different location
than any of the other DC movies before
so the next time they roll out an
Aquaman movie they won't have to worry
about doing that quite so hard like
people will understand the concept like
Oh
Atlantis yeah we've seen that we know
what that looks like Shazam is the first
magic-based character that we've seen in
the DC Universe and it's the first kid
this is a superhero or kid with
superpowers for the entire duration of
the film like you get a little bit of
young Wonder Woman you get a little bit
of young Superman you even get a little
bit of young Aquaman but Shazam is a
little kid from start-to-finish he just
looks like an adult during different
times like they play in a lot of the
comedy of like well you look like an
adult now so why don't we try to do
things that only adults are allowed to
do like buy some beer so for everybody
that was confused by all the weird jump
cuts in all the previous trailers where
they walk out after stopping the robbery
there's a jump cut and then it's him
saying hey I'm a superhero and they all
suddenly have bags of candy and chips
instead of all the bottles of beer that
they initially walked out with then in
the last trailer we actually got that
beer scene your finest beer please this
special preview gives us some missing
footage where they walk out with that
beer take a drink
spit it out oh that tastes like vomit
then obviously they go back in and get
all the junk food and then you get that
scene where he says hey I'm a superhero
there's a couple new scenes of him
testing his powers you see him shoot
lightning bolts out of his finger and
he's really surprised like oh my god I
can shoot lightning then you see them in
the mall and you find out what they're
doing they're like they had the funny
moment in the previous trailers where
he's charging everyone's phones but this
is on route to the ATM machine where he
shocks it and a bunch of cash starts
flying out so that's actually a moment
right out of Jeff Jon's new 52 Shazam
run it's all stuff that he does really
early right after he gets powers because
it's like wait a minute we can do
anything we want I have superpowers and
I look like an adult let's go have some
fun
so that also probably leads to him
busking in the crowd here for money
using his powers like he's shooting
lightning bolts but you see the guitar
case on the ground there like he's
asking people for money this seems like
it's right before dr. sivana shows up
and challenges him but I think the
funnier thing about this scene isn't
that he's busking for money in the crowd
it's the idea that a child would think
that's the best way to earn money with
superpowers like that like if you were a
superhero and you really thought about
it there are way faster ways to earn
money with your abilities we'll circle
back around to that idea when we get to
the Booster Gold movie eventually they
did actually fast-track a Blue Beetle
movie but I don't know when that's
coming and I don't know if Booster Gold
is still supposed to be in it because a
couple years ago they started working on
a Blue Beetle Booster Gold movie but now
it seems like it's just gonna be a Blue
Beetle movie we get a couple more scenes
of him at the rock of eternity when he's
getting his powers a lot of you have
correctly spotted this flashback and
what seems like dr. sivana when he was
Billy's age also a potential candidate
to replace the wizard as the protector
of the seven deadly sins the director of
the producers did a big interview where
they talked about Superman Black Adam
the seven deadly sins what they
explained is as they're essentially
using the seven deadly sins in the movie
the same way that the Aquaman movie used
the trench so they're talked about with
a great level of caution and fear
Billy's whole role the reason why the
wizard is passing his abilities on to
him is so that he can guard the world
against the seven deadly sins because
they're quite literally called the seven
deadly enemies of man in the comics it's
pride Envy greed anger sloth gluttony
and lust so early prediction dr. sivana
probably tries to release them the same
way that Black Adam did during the new
52 Shazam run I talked a little bit
about what they're changing in the story
from the comics so they're adapting that
very first Geoff Johns new 52 Shazam run
but black Adam was a really big part of
that and they're kind of separating that
part of it out to the next big film that
they do think there's not gonna be a lot
of black Adam going on during the Shazam
movie but dr. sivana is a very big part
of that story as well so they're giving
some of that black Adams story to dr.
sivana and in the comics he was
technically never a candidate for the
powers of Shazam but the movie is saying
that he was things went badly
which is also kind of a black atom comic
book Easter egg because he got the
powers of Shazam about 5,000 years ago
turned evil went insane and the wizard
never forgave himself until Billy Batson
came along but when the director was
asked about a Superman cameo during the
film in a black Adam maybe post-credits
scene they didn't say no but they kind
of talked around it they're like well
it's a DC movie you know Superman is a
really big character Black Adam is very
critical to the Canon of the Shazam
comics they also confirmed that there
would be a mid-credits scene they didn't
say how many post-credit scenes but
there'll be at least one mid-credits
scene so just based on the way they
talked about it I'm assuming there's
some sort of Superman Easter Egg towards
the end of the film or in that
mid-credits scene and also a black Adam
moment separately but the Black Adam
movie is actually I think supposed to
start production next year in the tone
is gonna be wildly different if you've
ever smelled anything that the rock has
ever cooked in any of his movies then
you have a pretty good idea for what the
Black Adam movie is gonna be like it'll
be him smashing people for two hours
straight I'm also expecting some sort of
wink at the Shazam family because they
have the whole Shazam family in the film
the whole concept of family is really
important for the Shazam character and
the family itself was really big during
that Jeff John's new 52 run so it's
Freddy Freeman this is Mary Marvel here
this is Pedro this is Eugene and this is
Darla so pretty solid chance that
towards the end of the film to get their
powers and then they play with that a
little bit more when they get to the
inevitable Shazam sequel the other
really big DC news you may have heard is
that they announced an Aquaman spin-off
called the trench is literally a movie
about the trench just because it was
such a big part of the film that they
didn't spend a lot of time explaining
they talked about it a lot and they swam
through the trench really quickly a
couple times but that was about it
so they didn't say what kind of
characters they're gonna use or whether
or not Jason Momoa is gonna be a big
part of it or if he's only gonna be in a
little bit of it which other main
characters they're gonna do or when it's
gonna come out they just announced that
James 1 is developing it I don't know if
he's gonna direct it Warner Brothers
also just hired a writer for Aquaman 2
we don't know what it's gonna be about
but I've already done an Aquaman
post-credit scene video that I'll link
at the end of this where I talk a little
bit about potential sequels to it
because it's really big underwater
universe that they just introduced
there's just a lot of potential story
areas for them to mine particularly the
Aqua
comics which actually go pretty deep on
mythology Jason Momoa also said he's
gonna try and get a Wonder Woman cameo
and her future movies like Wonder Woman
three and anything else she does after
that will be set in present-day so it'll
be a lot easier for them to logically
cross Wonder Woman over with Aquaman
stuff but in terms of crossing Shazam
over with other Justice League
characters I think a lot of it just
depends on how the Shazam movie does but
I think the idea was before they sort of
postponed future Justice League sequels
is that eventually he would join the
Justice League as well but we're still
waiting on that flash movie we have Matt
Reeves Batman film so there's still a
lot of other stuff that has to happen
before Shazam joins the Justice League
there's a whole bunch of comic book
stuff that's happening this week that
I'll try to get to as fast as possible
but click here for that Aquaman
post-credit scene and click here for my
brand-new Captain Marvel trailer and New
Avengers endgame thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]